For the iconic role of the Joker in Suicide
Squad, Jared Leto got into incredible shape
and focused on building serious muscle definition.
Now, he's hitting the gym again to get ready
to star as the title character in the upcoming
Spider-Man spinoff film, Morbius.
The personal training sessions for Suicide
Squad were no joke.
Under the guidance of trainer Brendan Johnston,
the entire cast got fit together while staying
at a training facility in Toronto for what
they described as "boot camp."
Johnston had specific exercises in mind for
each cast member, depending on what their
character would be doing on screen.
According to Men's Journal, Johnston wanted
Leto to look like an MMA fighter by the time
he was done working with him.
How did he achieve that?
For starters, Leto's regular workouts consisted
of plenty of bodybuilding exercises and weighted
calisthenics.
He also practiced boxing, and Johnston noted
that Leto was, quote, "throwing a lot of punches
throughout the day."
Leto's regular routines also included daily
cardio.
The cast typically got one day off after every
four days they spent in the gym, so there
was also some mandatory rest time.
Leto is living proof that you don't need to
eat meat in order to build muscle.
According to an interview with GQ, Leto has
been vegan for over two decades.
Clearly, it's working out pretty well for
him, as he credits his vegan lifestyle for
his health.
He does admit to cheating every once in a
while and indulging in treats that contain
milk or eggs.
But he draws the line at consuming meat, even
on special occasions.
A vegan chef comes on tour with Thirty Seconds
to Mars — even when the band did their "Carnivores
Tour" with Linkin Park, Leto was still fueling
up on fruits and vegetables backstage.
In 2014, he was named PETA's "Sexiest Vegan."
To get ready to play the Joker, Leto had to
eat every two hours throughout the day to
keep his energy up and his metabolism working
hard.
So, what's Leto's number one fitness secret?
His primary piece of advice is something that
seems so obvious, yet many people still underestimate
its importance.
When it comes to looking your best, Leto told
Rolling Stone,
"I would tell everyone to sleep as much as
you can."
With his crazy schedule, he knows that it's
crucial to get that full eight hours of sleep
every night.
From concerts to the gym to the recording
studio to the set of whatever film he's working
on, he needs to be able to perform at his
best every moment of the day.
Some people assume that musicians and actors
would rather go out every night than crawl
into bed early, but for Leto, this isn't the
case.
It's easy to assume that an actor who dives
deeply into their roles like Leto might be
experimenting with certain substances off
screen.
After all, he did live on the street with
addicts to prepare for his role in Requiem
for a Dream.
But even then, Leto didn't partake, and he
says that at this point, he's been totally
straight edge for many years — no drugs
or alcohol.
Leto admitted to getting into some trouble
in his younger days due to his previous alcohol
and drug use.
However, he eventually changed his ways, and
he knows that he made the right choice.
He told Rolling Stone,
"I guess at some point, too, there's a decision:
Is this going to be my life?
I made a choice to pursue other dreams…
the risk versus reward is out of line.
I just saw too many examples of what not to
do."
Leto hasn't yet given any specific details
about his workouts for Morbius.
However, he does post pretty frequently on
Instagram.
So far, it looks like he's been working out
on his elliptical, and he also says that he's
been going for daily morning bike rides — even
while he's on tour.
Of course, touring is a workout in itself.
"It's kind of like a master spinning aerobics
class, Richard Simmons would be proud."
Although he hasn't posted about any bodybuilding
workouts yet, he's most likely sticking with
a lifting routine as well.
Rock climbing is also one of Leto's favorite
hobbies.
Whether he's trying to get in shape for a
particular role or not, he always makes time
to climb.
He told Rolling Stone climbing is also a form
of stress relief for him, and a way to stay
balanced in the chaotic world of Hollywood.
Morbius isn't due out for release until July
2020, with shooting having commenced in March
2019.
But you can bet, with his unmatched commitment
to his work, Leto is sure to deliver as the
star.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.